angle and just kind of put him to sleep
what he's thinking
about in that moment he actually told me
that bro
he said it was his father's favorite
submission so when he got there
he was going to do the arm bar but he
had heard justin all week say
deep in that moment where he's getting
punched and gage is giving him some
kicks
he is thinking that gives me goosebumps
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah before
i start one place i was surprised
most the most merciful the most trust of
praise is glory and gratitude
belong to him before you start the video
problem sisters just to keep you
guys in mind it's winter times have gone
back an hour
are one after another so make sure you
guys do not miss your salah
just a little reminder because reminder
benefits a believer now
obviously we know the whole khabib thing
is hot now everybody's talking about
it um and alhamdulillah we're trying to
gain a lot of benefits out of that
khabib as a person we've discussed many
times as a character
he's outstanding as a character as
individual the field that he's in
himself he has
like in the context of hitting the face
punching the face of haram it's as
simple as that
i follow the opinion and i believe it's
the strongest opinion
but i just want to make that clear so
i'm not here to promote because i'm not
a hypocrite i'm not going to come here
and just because khabib is so well it
doesn't matter the dean comes before
anything and khabib himself has said
that he knows allah is not pleased with
what he's doing anyways so for
anyone that's justifying yeah i thought
you guys are going to matter in the
comments that's not about what this
video is about
this video is about habib's character
and now brothers and sisters the prophet
salallahu said
i came for nothing but to perfect good
character
now this is very important the prophet
sallallahu alaiha told us one of the two
things heaven in their judgment is what
tawheed the wonders of allah believing
in his worship and
him alone worshiping him and
we're about to find out why good
character
has been emphasized so much from the
self to
the sahaba the sahaba the first reject
the two three generations
to the prophet sallam and why allah has
subhanallah mentioned that in the quran
about his upmost
beautiful character that the prophet
peace be upon him have
this is a video which will leave you
amazed because it did leave me amazed
we're going to find out why khabib chose
not not to
put justin gage's arm in a lock where it
will cause
it to break let's find out very
interesting
there were a number of little things
that played into
uh the the justin gaichi submission
right now i'm
grabbing my phone because i want to read
this i spoke to habibi yesterday and
we were talking about it and i said i
want to make sure i say it the right way
um he told me when he was watching the
interviews over the course of the week
right he saw that justin said he would
never tap justin would never tap
and so when he was going to the
submission he said that's
his dad's favorite submission right get
into the mounting position going to the
arm bar going to the triangle
he said it was his father's favorite
submission so when he got there
he was going to do the arm bar but he
had heard justin all week saying he
would never tap
and he didn't want to hurt him in front
of his parents
so he went to the triangle
let me get this right let me get this
right
you're in if you're fighting somebody
you're in the zone of fighting the first
thing that will go from my head is how
to knock the opponent out
or to protect myself somehow i'm not
thinking about nobody's parents at the
moment yeah
khabib in that moment where he's getting
punched and gage is giving him some
kicks
he is thinking look at the emotional
intelligence he has that a lot of us in
the dua
a lot of us in the tower scene or as
muslims we don't we don't care the last
person we think about is that we're just
subhan allah and we have ego we have ego
that we would think in the fact but i'm
gonna smash i'm gonna prove that
i'm the man you know i'm gonna break his
arm i'm gonna take his nose out brother
i'm gonna pluck his eyes out
just to show how big of a man you are
this is the attitude some of us men have
and the stronger we try to look the
weaker you are look what habib does
and look what these people say these are
non-muslims
and just kind of put him to sleep what
he's thinking about
in that moment he actually told me that
bro he goes i didn't want to hurt him in
front of his parents
so i said i'm going to go and put him in
the triangle and then if he goes to
sleep go to sleep you wake up you're
fine
the guy is he's like what he was
thinking about that in that moment
brothers and sisters this is amazing and
i want to come to why it's so amazing
let's just finish this off inshallah
exactly what he told me that's crazy all
right he did not want to hurt justin in
front of his parents
that gives me goosebumps to have the i
mean to be comfortable enough to think
about this
in the moment you know like that's crazy
he
he didn't want to break his arm because
if justin's not going to tap you have to
break it and he didn't want to do that
to him in front of his mom and dad so
he said if i put him to sleep he'll wake
up and and everything will be okay
you'll be okay
guys in today's time where we live
where a must certain muslims the way
they treat other believers
yeah when allah says those who are soft
towards the believers and harsh towards
the enemies of allah
some of them do it opposite way and how
they treat muslims
harshly you're harsh towards others
always harsh and picking and this that
khabib had mercy to a he's not even
anywhere was he
we haven't seen anything from justin
about that he's an enemy of allah yeah
but as a non-muslim yeah
like he could go there and break his arm
to prove a point and say you know what
brother i've destroyed him
man i broke his arm you can see
brothers and sisters when we speak to
people and we say this in itself when
the prophet sallallahu
talked about adam and character this is
it when you look at khabib
is ever made career to a side him as a
character how he
is obedient to his parents his
relationship with his allah him even
sitting down to drink following the
sunnah
he's following the sunnated even when he
was ordering burger he goes no onion i'm
assuming maybe i'm assuming the best
he doesn't want to have bad breath you
know you know because the idea for the
process
is garlic maybe but still you can see
that not only
and the guy is following the sunnah in
aspects he is
dedicated and at that moment of time he
is thinking
and what did they say they said it was
one of his dad's favorite submission
the arm thing yeah it was his favorite
and his dad's passed away he could have
said look in the memphis like you know
my dad's favorite so much
i'm breaking the arm and you know how
much he loves his dad he puts that to
his side
he said his parents are watching and
justin said what i'm not going to tap
out
yeah that means you give up i'm not
going to do that
so therefore he he could easily he said
no no i'm not going to do that because
look he might he might be a bit stubborn
and i'm going to have to break his arm
he goes to the try and triangle
lock yeah submission and puts him to
sleep because when he gets
once he when he gets up at least he's
okay and he's not injured to that
extent look at the mercy he has on his
opponent
look at the mercy of his opponents
brothers and sisters this
is tawheed i repeat again i'm talking
about the mma side
him as a character imagine the prophet
salallahu if non-muslims are so
touched the da'wah that habib is doing
nobody can match it nobody can match it
you know why because brothers and
sisters
brothers and sisters when people look at
people like muhammad ali
when people look and if i'm saying
muhammad ali when he was having a
match of george foreman if i'm mistaken
and george foreman said when he was
going down muhammad ali could have given
another blow
and he said when he did it and i saw
that you know he just thought i'm
it's done yeah he goes i respected him
more well i said he's the greatest and
allah the grace but you know what i'm
saying
you can see that your outer character
and the way you carry yourself and your
principles
is the biggest form of dawah you can
talk as much as you like good answer now
select
like a robot with algorithms but people
look at your actions and character and
see how you carry yourself
and this is why it's so fundamental so
important for us to read ourselves of
arrogance
and not think that this religion is
superficial of how many books i have
behind me and
you know how many times i'll use the
word yanny and tahid and shep and bidder
and brothers and sisters his character
people
all around the world non-muslims muslims
look at him and be like bro i want to be
like him it's a
good role model the way he carries
himself brother sisters and
non-muslims are testifying i'm thinking
man this guy is a great guy
nowadays no muslims did they did they
read the quran did they read the prophet
sallallahu assalam's hadith
did they know about islam did they study
islam
never but wallahi and this is what we're
talking about
and this is when subhanallah which
whenever i visit shakhitham
and this is one of the nasir this
shakhtar gave to certain brothers as
well
character character the way you carry
yourself even though these brothers
oppress them
even though these brothers oppressed him
alhamdulillah brother abbott
may i bless him while i may have blessed
him came out and
asked for repentance for that specific
thing but that's another issue but the
importance is this when sheikh hatham
when i see him and he talks about
you have to contextualize contextualize
what he means so he brothers and sisters
to represent islam
is not to go and shall blame allah allah
is one
we've seen that happening with andrew
and his likes
where does that get us do people look at
people like andrew choudhary
and these individuals say i want to know
more about islam it seems so interesting
wow when these attacks happen do you
think these do you think non-muslims
come and say
i found islam so interesting no khabib
like
the process
is like the walking talking quran his
character his adam so much soul and we
honor him
and people are trying to insult him the
french macarooni where this
name is this two-faced viral animal
trying to come
and justify insulting the prophet when
he himself and i've got another video
coming for him
don't worry soon inshallah and i'm
pressing our brothers and sisters in
france we've got
we've got some stuff coming out
inshallah and the prophet salallahu his
own
enemies would give their goods gold can
you imagine somebody that hates your
guts come and says you know what i trust
you you're
you're you're the truth you're truthful
can look after my god can you cost my
money
this is and we will defend this
honor till the death of us brothers and
sisters
i just wanted this video to be a
reminder and we're going to end this
video with habib ordering a cheeseburger
i found that quite funny you can watch
it insha'allah
to emphasize for those who think dawa is
done by you know having so much
knowledge
and having a youtube channel
i swear upon the rub of the kaaba
dawa is done with your attack the way
you carry yourself
let people see to heed the oneness
of allah in your achlach in your adapt
so much so
that they say i want to know what makes
this person so beautiful in character
what has cultivated this individual so
much
that the way they carry their self the
way they are with their parents
the way they are with their religion
with their lord
and this is what is the greatest form
of dawah brothers and sisters
haven't come aggressive but passionate
and may allah make us amongst those
that enable and give dawah
with their actions and adap rather than
a few words
that they have memorized till next time
well done cheeseburger and beef
can i have
you don't want to make cheeseburger you
don't like to get
only this okay
everything mix i want